this windswept beach in the southeast of
scotland is open to the public but to
get here
there's a bit of effort required
that is part of the ely chain walk 500
metres long made up of eight chains
anchored into the cliff face along with
some carved foot and handholds it was
set up in the 1920s likely to help local
fishermen get down the cliffs to their
boats a century later it's maintained as
a local attraction and as an optional
side trip on the local coast path which
means that in any weather even on very
blustery ill-advised freezing days like
this you can just scramble along the
chain walkers if it was any other public
footpath now you should not do this
alone i've got a local guide with me
thank you alan and before we set off i
asked him about how all this works it's
open to the public completely open
access all year round you do need a
certain level of physical ability you're
putting a lot of your weight
onto your arms it's a couple of chains
you have to just climb and descend from
a reasonably high height
and so although it's technically not
difficult you do have to be cautious
climbing at height if you come here in
the summer you'll see families tackling
the chains but also groups come here
with helmets and harnesses and so on so
a wide range of people come and give the
chains a go
very occasionally people do fall here
perhaps because they've ignored the
safety signs or strayed off the path or
been trapped by the tide and had to call
out the local lifeboat the chain walk
isn't massively dangerous it's not just
for climbing experts but it is dangerous
enough that the safety signs are
justified there are modern attractions
like this all over the world but they
generally use harness systems instead of
hold on tight and watch out for the tide
the chainwalk sits in that strange group
of lesser-known places where it would
never be created now
but it does exist and no one wants to
get rid of it it was repaired about 10
years ago after someone stole the chains
and every six months engineers come out
to check that everything is still
anchored in safe and intact one thing
you might notice that some of the the
fixing points move
and so quite often we'll have people
reporting them in but that's actually
meant to be like that there's meant to
be a little bit of movement so it
doesn't stress the rock as much i've
been coming here and leading groups here
for for about 30 years plan ahead and
secondly come prepared decent footwear
know the tides know what the weather's
going to be like so that you don't get
surprised
as you go along the chains there have
been reports
of people falling they see the tide they
feel trapped they don't want to get wet
so they decide to climb up the cliffs
but if you know the tides and if you
plan around that then that's not going
to happen when i first came here it was
the original chains which were old and
rusty the ones there now are quite new
and shiny and
solid and what i love most about this is
the chain walk doesn't really lead
anywhere important you go across some
cliffs down a bit across up again and
you get access to a couple of beaches
that are pretty much like every other
beach around here people do this people
take a small but significant risk and
take the chain walk for
no other reason than
it's there
you